joining me now is jonathan turley george
washington university law professor fox
news contributor uh professor i do want
to get your reaction to the question i
just asked senator lee
what happens let's first start with the
vaccine mandates that are in place now
we have the challenge now against the
military vaccine mandate coming out of
oklahoma tonight we have the other
vaccine mandate questions for health
care workers they're all going to end up
at the supreme court how do things look
with that jacobson precedent with
smallpox from all those years ago
well it's been a remarkably bad run for
the white house they've racked up a
number of losses in notably different
areas these are mandates related to
federal contractors
uh also a mandate with regard to
medicare
dealing with uh
facilities and then of course the big
osha ruling and all of those courts said
that they don't see at the preliminary
injunction stage
the clear authority for the government
to do what it did in fact the fifth
circuit cited uh biden's own chief of
staff ron claine who really um was
um really ill-con
advised when he uh cited the or
retweeted a statement that this was all
a workaround that is it acknowledged
that they didn't have the constitutional
authority to do this directly and so
clained retweeted that we found a
workaround well the fifth circuit cited
that
courts don't take to workarounds in the
constitution they like to see direct
authority
and many of the problems that they've
encountered has been an effort to avoid
notice and comment they used an
emergency
provision under osha that allowed them
to skip that another court
found that to be also a problem in
another mandate
so there's a host of issues here that
courts are flagging
and they're really racking up quite a
litany of losses
now one of the issues professor
um that
much of this is being driven by things
like tv doctors who are saying really
outrageous things like this
our major tool
is vaccination so you know the biden
administration is doing everything it
can
within the power of the federal
government the problem is by
constitutional design the way
madison and jefferson did this there are
limits to the reach of the federal
government
they're really annoyed at the founders
they really don't like the fact that we
have a constitutional republic
that annoys these people who want total
medical control over individuals
well it's it's rather ironic since the
democrats you know
really took donald trump to task when
they believed that he was acting
unilaterally
this is an extra constitutional move in
some regards keep in mind that with the
cdc eviction moratorium in another area
the president acknowledged that he was
told by his own white house counsel that
that moratorium
was likely unconstitutional he
acknowledged that most legal experts
that they spoke to said it was
unconstitutional they could only find
one apparently lawrence tribe who gave
it a green light
and he said you know what we're going to
go forward because by the time it takes
them to strike this down
we'll get a lot of money out of the door
well the court's made fast work of it
but there's this this reckless attitude
of the administration towards some of
this litigation
these losses cost the executive branch
they're creating precedent not just
against this president but future
president and jonathan really quickly
because we're out of time but on this
domestic travel ban which they're
itching they're clearly itching to
impose on the unvaccinated
in your in your estimation
what are the like what's the likelihood
that that would survive constitutional
scrutiny
well they have considerable authority in
that area so it could end up a close
question but i got to tell you courts
are showing greater and greater
skepticism you have to make the case you
can't just simply say uh we have a new
variant uh the courts are now asking
those questions they didn't ask at the
beginning of the pandemic
they're all from missouri and they're
saying show me
yeah well
depriving individuals of their right to
travel uh in interstate
is one of the most stunning things
we've never i mean we've never heard of
that in the united states before i don't
believe jonathan thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else